I'm going to tell a story. I don't know if you know, um,
but when you ran for president in 2016, um,
you started like the pack to end all packs. Um, and I donated,
I was like, wow, great idea. This guy is onto something.
Know now the story of my story, I actually think of as a story of optimism,
because, you know, in 2016 it was my view.
It's actually 2015 when we started this,
it was my view that unless we got the nation to focus on the
fundamental problem of the corruption of this democracy,
nothing else was possible. I mean, you know,
you got these candidates like Bernie and Hillary up on stage talking about all
the amazing things they're going to do.
And onstage too, man. But we thought about that. What was up?
They changed the rules on you, right?
Yeah. So, so I wanted to get them to focus on these fundamental issues.
And I said like,
I will run for president if I can raise a million dollars in 30 days. And, um,
and the way I'd run for president is by making this issue, the number one issue,
the issue I talked about before, anything else,
like we have to commit to fixing democracy first.
And so we raised the money in less than 30 days. And, uh.
Then when you're like, Oh my gosh, now I have to do it right.
But the pollsters that we, you know, we had said, look, um, based on what we,
we know you're going to qualify for the debates.
The first challenge was that the democratic party had a rule that said that you
had to be, uh,
you had to be listed on a certain list of polls and those polling companies were
not including my name. Um.
No, I just wanted to stop you there. Lawrence,
that was actually really tricky for us too. In 2018, they lived,
they had a bunch of poles and my name was not on them. And then you're like,
well, if I'm not on the poll, it's going to be very hard to qualify.
So leading up to the first debate, uh, Bloomberg.
Wrote a,
the Bloomberg press wrote a big editorial about how ridiculous this was,
because you could tell from other polling that I would have qualified,
but I wasn't on the approved list. My view at that point was okay.
Their rule was here's the approved list. You gotta be on that list. Fine.
The next time around, we'll make it a week before. Uh, yeah,
at the end of October, um, uh, my campaign manager called me and he said,
you know, we're going to qualify. You're going to be in the next debate. Um,
and I said, Oh, you know, he said, you got to get to work and preparing.
So I drilled down to begin to prepare. And then at the end of the week,
he called me back and he said, uh,
the Democrat party has just changed the rules for the debate.
You're not going to qualify. And they had,
they had recrafted the rule to like draw the boundary
precisely so that I would not qualify according to their new specified
rules. Um, and, uh, and so, you know.
It was clear they were going to change. What was the new boundary?
What was the old boundary? What was the new?
So the rules they had originally announced, which they eventually agreed this,
where there were rules with that. You had to be at 1% in three polls,
within six weeks of the debate, very reasonable. And then they, uh,
changed the rules to say, you had to be greater than 1% in three polls.
And then they gave a period carving out the time before the debate.
And that period was carved to lop off poles that had
qualified me. And then we knew what other polls were going to be announced.
And there weren't going to be enough polls that were announced to qualify.
Me at that point. That was a coincidence.
They consulted the stars.
It was at 70% off that could form to somebody wrote me and said,
uh.
Yeah, pulse of the nation, right. Somebody wrote me and said,
that's what Larry Mandarin born, because
that's fine. But anyway, the point was, it was clear.
They didn't want somebody up on stage causing trouble around this issue. And,
you know, they saw what Donald Trump was doing on the, on the Republican Sage.
I don't blame them in some sense, but they didn't want this issue to be central.
When I tried to talk about this issue as being central, people are like, no,
I don't know. People care about health care. They care about,
they care about climate change. They care about student debt.
I was like the danger Larry is that, um.
It, it, it seems no offense to you, but you seem like a very smart guy.
So.
The danger, when you talk about the end, you should know that, um, I,
I came away also convinced by our event together where I was like, he's right.
Uh, democracy reform needs to be front and center because we'll never actually
change anything meaningful without it. Um, but the, the, the hazard,
I think that people have,
when you talk about it is they think in terms of process,
that's what I meant by the smart guy. It's like a smart guy.
You have some fixes to the process. Uh, and the,
the danger is that people will just be like, Oh, you know,
like this stuff is going to be wonky and uninteresting,
but it seems like you've had a different experience when you talk about this,
because Americans realize that we right now are not functioning in
a democracy that is living up to the name.
Yeah. And this is what's so hopeful. I think, you know, in 2016,
I couldn't get them to talk about this year in 2020, you know,
our group and represent us in end citizens United succeeded in getting every
major democratic candidate.
You were one of the first to commit to fundamental democratic reform in the
first hundred days of their administration, including finally, uh, um,
Joe Biden. But I thought most dramatically was Bernie Sanders,
who finally came around to embracing vouchers,
which you had embraced back in April of 2019.
And he had an incredibly powerful story about why vouchers were so fundamental
shifting power to ordinary voters so that they are the one driving fundraising
and the intention of candidates. Um, and so, you know,
my view is we've come a long way in five years. We came from the issue,
not even being recognized. No, it's not me. I mean,
there are a lot of people that helped you, a lot of people, right?
Think about this issue though. Uh, you are the first name that comes to mind,
right?
So, so I think we're at this moment where, you know,
the house of representatives passed HR one in 2019,
the most important reform legislation passed by the house since the voting
rights act of 1965. Um, if we get the Senate,
if we send the dark Lord Mitch McConnell back to Kentucky, um, and, uh,
we get the presidency, there is a chance that a year from now, we will look at,
uh, what happened and say, Holy, we have passed fundamental reform,
including public funding, aggressional campaigns.
And I hope I'm including something more like what you were talking about
vouchers to help drive that funding and that democracy dollars. Yeah, yeah.
Which is what you were very clear right upfront. And then it was so funny,
Kirsten Gillibrand, his campaign I was talking to, and they're like,
Andrew Yang says a hundred dollars, hell, we're going to say $600,
$600 for voter of, if you have three, three campaigns,
a president Senate and house in, in one cycle. So you sparked it. Yes,
that's right.
So I think we have a real shot if we can just get beyond the
disaster that is looming in November of 2010.
This is very optimistic and HR one has many tremendous
reforms in it. Um,
what are like the top reforms that you're excited about?
And to the extent HR one's missing anything, is it missing something? Yeah.
The most important thing in HR, one is public funding.
It's missing a more robust voucher components because the kind of
public funding it's framed around is matching funds,
which is what New York city does. And matching funds are great, very helpful.
But the point is you're still appealing to a relatively small slug of pig.
I mean, you know, most,
most rich people don't realize that the average American can't just write a
check for a hundred dollars to a politician.
That's just not within their capacity,
but if they had a hundred dollars democracy dollar,
the way you were talking about it, of course,
what else are you going to do with it? They're going to give it to politicians.
So the point is, that's a more fundamental reform we've got to build in.
And I know the sponsors of HR one are eager to think about how to expand it.
So H O one,
that's the most important thing that gerrymandering reform is incredibly
important.
The restoration of the voting rights act is astonishing that we're still
fighting about this issue, but yes, that's incredibly important.
What it's missing is, is much stronger support for rank choice.
Voting would have been,
would have been extremely important in this democratic primary, um, uh, um,
you know, as well as having an Iowa caucus that actually worked,
that would have been helpful too. But, um, you know,
I think that that's something a lot of people are talking about now we could,
we could begin to get towards. Um,
but I think those are the central and most important things at that bill.
Well, it's, it would be a great leap forward to have, um,
matching funds for these congressional campaigns,
because some of the candidates we're seeing are generating popular enthusiasm,
and that if you got a bunch of small dollar donors, uh, it could add up quickly.
But I agree with you.
People don't realize what a big deal it is for someone to donate 10, 20,
50 bucks to a political campaign. Uh,
one people don't have any disposable income lying around in that way.
Like if you think 50, a hundred dollars to them, that's like a really big deal.
But the second thing is people are so burnt by politics that it,
it takes like a really big, uh,
connection or attachment to motivate someone to donate to a candidate.
It's one reason why I'm so appreciative of the yang gang, um,
rallying behind my campaign because I was really bad at dialing for dollars. Uh,
Larry, I was terrible at it. So I was like, Oh man,
I hope some everyday America.
The worst, you know, when I was doing it.
And I did it very little when we came to, you know,
close to getting to the million dollars,
my campaign manager sat me down and he said,
you've got to call these people and make sure it happens. Okay. So I did it,
but the thing I was thinking as I was doing it as, okay, I hate this.
Every normal person would hate this. What kind of person likes this?
Because you know,
that's the kind of person we're attracting to run for Congress. And you're like,
do we really want our nation represented by the sort of person who likes sucking
up to rich people from money?
Because that's not how you build leadership in an issue.
I joke about it all the time that you'd have to be out of your mind to go to a
cubicle farm and dial for dollars and think that was the way it ought to be.
The problem is that as soon as you're in that cubicle farm, then you're like,
well, I had to swim through to get here. Yeah.
And so now this system's going to protect me because I'm an incumbent.
I start out with, let's say a million dollar advantage over, uh,
Tom Dick or Harry or Sally or whoever was going to run against me. Uh,
so here it is like this moat now benefits me.
So I guess, uh,
I will suck it up and take advantage of the fact that I can do a soul crushing
activity better than the next person.
The most depressing story I heard was a member of Congress told me, he said,
you know, one of the things about Congress is it's totally broken institution.
Nothing happens.
And it turns out fundraising is the one thing where you feel like you've
accomplished something. So it's like doing pushups. So he says like,
I can go down for an hour and I can have my target and I can meet my target.
I can feel like, Holy, I did something. I accomplished something today.
And you're like, Oh my God, this system is now built.
So that the only thing you feel proud of is your ability to raise money because
you can't do anything else. You can't legislate. You can't work with anybody.
You can't bring about government services.
Anybody's respectful of it's just fundraising. That is the measure of success.
That is very dark and very human and so important.
Uh, there was a person running for president.
Hopefully he doesn't mind that I say this. Uh, but Senator Michael Bennet,
and one of my colleagues was with them on the plane and was like, Hey,
so, uh, what's motivating the run. And he said, honestly,
it's so I can try and get something done because I'm not getting done in the
Senate because we don't pass anything. Yeah. Uh,
and so it speaks to the same thing where if you have a good person who wants to
accomplish something, unfortunately dialing for dollars,
at least gives them that momentary reinforcement,
that that day they got something good, done, or good quotes. They succeeded.
That's such a microcosm of something. I think.
So one of the things I said on the trail was that in
American life today, if you have money on one side and people on the other,
the money is going to win, who's going to win.
And people all like uniformly in my events. They were like, yeah,
the money is going to win. And so this is the case I made for democracy dollar.
I said, we have to unify the people in the money and then you have a chance.
Then the legislators are responding to you again.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.